اندلعت فرصة الغضب والتحدي في
مدينة جنين في
صباح اليوم التالي بعد انسحاب الجيش الإسرائيلي
الآلاف ملأوا الشوارع لدفن
القتلى ،
يقول الجيش الإسرائيلي إن جميع القتلى الـ 12
في توغله كانوا مقاتلين
وأن عمليته كانت تهدف إلى
تفكيك شبكات الإرهاب هنا ولكن
يقول هذا الأب إنه فخور بأن يبلغ من العمر 19 عامًا ما
يسميه شهيدًا وكان
مقاتلًا مع أحد الفصائل الفلسطينية المسلحة التي
قُتلت في التوغل ،
أخبرني ابني أنه لا يريد
الزواج أو تكوين أسرة كما يقول  قال إن
كل ما أراد فعله هو تكريس
حياته لفلسطين لمحاربة
الاحتلال ، وسرعان ما تتحول هذه الجنازة
إلى مظاهرة
للمقاومة العديد من الفصائل الفلسطينية المسلحة
هنا لإظهار أنها
لم تنكسر بسبب العرق الإسرائيلي
للعديد من الفلسطينيين جانين هي  اسم
ومكان مرادفان للمعاناة والمقاومة
ولكن هذه المعركة جاءت
بتكلفة باهظة في أعقاب
ترك سكان المخيم بدون
مياه جارية وكهرباء أو خدمات أساسية
وعادت العائلات إلى المنازل المدمرة
وتقول إنها وبناتها الثلاث
وقعن في مرمى النيران.  لقد
اصطحبتني إلى الطابق العلوي لتريني ما
تبقى من غرفة ابنتها
يقول الجيش الإسرائيلي إنه حقق
أهدافه العملياتية في القضاء على
مستودعات الأسلحة ومراكز القيادة في جنين ،
لكنه أيضًا عمّق الكراهية
وحفز المقاومة في مدينة
تشتهر دائمًا بالرد.  بعض
من هؤلاء سي إن إن جانين